[Music]
in racism fail news awesome like they
tried to be racist and they can work out
submitted by Philly Asian Forge Amalia
hey Philadelphia ABM champion oh he's
old
that's an old mother that's true yeah a
woman called the cops on a black real
estate investor because she thought he
was a trespasser see the other two that
went viral too
it was the barbecue one and then the
lawyer one I saw the barbecue one oh my
god divorce I didn't see the lawyer one
but the barbecue one's hilarious I
watched the whole thing as a song it's
the same person I like this one because
the cops are so [ __ ] cool this is a
happy one that's what we decided to pick
this one instead of talking about the
other but the other one is [ __ ]
Barney - yeah because the cops are not
nice well I'll talk about after this
let's go this one okay so this takes
place in Tennessee you're the only ten I
see
I knew it I was like wait for it so you
bought your both fives just five yeah he
split it so you're both fine that's
jealousy talking you're the only ten I
see / - they wanted a compliment yeah
you guys are all so tense I stopped
listen to someone thank you
ten is low I'm like golf zero is the
best / call me a zero you're a golfer
zero in a tennis zero means left oh yeah
oh I like that
okay can we move on you started in a
hedge - yeah I gave you a compliment
ah she called you Geo I said [ __ ] okay
thank you
so Michael from Tennessee he went to go
visit this home in Memphis
oh this home cause he trying to flip it
make a profit you just started this
business and so the neighbors starts
getting crazy on him saying like you
have no right to be here up a little of
love and then
I'm gonna show you guys a clip of him
explaining the situation by the way he
was recording this entire time was like
a nine minute video on YouTube and you
see the how the officers react mmm it's
a really positive experience
that's Dell came out and asked what he
was doing something he understood I told
her what I was going so damn I sign in
the front yard told I had the paperwork
and everything the neighbor Tiffany
Albert told me Hayes didn't show her
paperwork she called the police
Hayes noted it in his video whatever
reason the neighbors called police owns
Albert didn't want Hayes at the house
suitor saying things like I have no
right to be there you know what am i
doing in the neighborhood get your sign
go Albert says the house had people
using drugs in it and other unsavory
activities the city finally boarded up
she did not want the board's removed it
took us so long to get these two places
boarded up - Luther showed up got
information from Hayes and realized he
had legitimate business at the house
officers talked with Albert he was still
not happy about his presence he says the
Memphis police officers handled the
situation in a very professional manner
and stayed at the scene while he did his
work understanding what's going on right
now in America with you know people
called the police on people for no
reason I understand that they could have
went a completely different way but when
they came out there they made me feel
safe I look like a racist on the video
I'm a boyfriend is black
it was nothing racial about it I don't
think it's racial either I think if if
this is a boarded up home and a lot of
people are doing crazy [ __ ] in there
she's gonna think that somebody's doing
crazy [ __ ] cuz we have a place next to
ours right now let my condo body of
people is boarded up now because he'll
of people doing drugs and their [ __ ]
like that and just [ __ ] it all up and
get him yeah but like even after the
cops were there and like they were
telling her like he has business to do
here she was like I've been hurry up her
hold it in the in the whole video she's
still aggressive after the fact that the
cop said he had
I think she was embarrassed that's what
I think Jack it's just her being it now
her being she's all I go hurry up
they're doing Allman know that so hurry
up is what I'm mad about yeah she's
embarrassed you know I didn't mean like
I I mean but then there was also a sign
in front of the house if it really was
yeah but people are sneaky they're like
III don't look at these situations and
think about the worst thing possible
because like I said in my condo that
happens a lot and so there are people in
there that always [ __ ] do drugs
they're like you know I mean like and if
if it's true that she they have been
petitioning to get that [ __ ] boarded up
and they see another person telling that
[ __ ] down to do it again and they seen
it over and over and over of course
she's gonna be pissed it's her
neighborhood so in the fact that she was
wrong that she's embarrassed now she's
like yeah the cops like well I know
people at the Sheriff's Department then
because she's embarrassed the cops were
like well I don't care if you know the
president but he's gonna be here and
he's gonna take as long as you want so
that was just really cool to see how the
cops reacted like finally it's like
refreshing like we don't see this yeah
versus cops coming on he's black I think
that was the I think that was the cool
thing about it is when the cops rolled
up they weren't aggressive toward him or
anything like that they were that should
be quiet they were they were actually on
his side like that [ __ ] was crazy and
then they took selfies together and yeah
then another neighbor came out and
started complaining about her as well
like I couldn't make out exactly what he
was saying but the neighbor was complain
yeah I haven't - my brother my brother
it gets really dark in the Sun but I
mean whatever he doesn't look black but
he looks you as a minority he was
training for a firefighter
whatever Academy yeah the Academy and so
you have to do hello like physical work
yeah and so he was doing like he was in
San Francisco so it's all city block
right and he would be running and then
he was doing like sit-ups on the
sidewalk
and I guess the neighbor called the cops
on him and said they there was a man
doing strange activity outside oh my god
he's like he's like doing push-ups in
this cop comes over like hey we got a
report that someone that fits your
description is doing strange activities
like I'm just doing push-ups man yeah
and the cops like okay you're good but
like that was it oh well speaking of the
bay that were the one that we were
talking about the 24 minute long video
where this lady so the lady in
do you have video that I don't oh please
just look for it right now cuz it's
gonna be worth looking at it I just
seriously it's way better to watch it
because the way she looks like have a
lawyer video but though but she's a meme
right now like she's in everything okay
like when I see these videos like I
always get I think in our pilot we want
to get angry so fast I'm only giving the
person than the benefit of doubt because
I hate it because even like me the mob
mentality mob mentality you know what I
mean so for me it's like I'd like to
think that she's not racist she's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I mean like you're
[ __ ] stupid is it different
yeah so here's a still of the video
they're calling her barbecue Becky look
at the way she looks
steven seagal sister or something the
backstory Segal is that she so it was
like these two black dudes by the lake
having a barbecue really chill relax
everything was clean but if they were
using a charcoal grill and then this
lady pulls up it's like she like the
black charcoal so then she started
saying this is illegal
you cannot barbecue here and then they
showed her the map of the part like this
is a designated area for barbecuing and
she was like well not for charcoal
charcoal is illegal and she just became
the frequency embarrassment once again
and then she actually stood there for
two hours she called the cops waited for
the cops for two hours and then this
white lady comes by and then she's
that's really like she starts recording
all this and so like by the time the
white lady shows up this lady starts to
be all nice giving her the white lady
treatment oh it's just I love that video
so much he's auditioning to be a member
of the NWA or something dude no boy and
the funniest part is when the cops roll
up her attitude changes immediately to
victim no before that like finally she
got on the phone with the cops again she
ends up taking a card from the white
lady as filming this video and so now
there's ladies like following her now
her harassing this [ __ ] because she's
like you stole my property give me my
card back give me my card back and she
would not give her her card right
because she pulled up her like business
card to show like I guess whatever they
were arguing about like I've been so she
snatched it out of her hand and put it
in her pocket yeah so the whole time she
wouldn't give her her card back and then
finally like she gets a hold of the
police and she starts fake breaking down
to the point where the cops are like
yeah it's so funny it's so funny because
like she's the one that put herself in
that [ __ ] situation no one asked you
to be the [ __ ] floor exactly no one
asked you to kick try to kick these
people out no one asked you to [ __ ]
stand there for two hours and wait for
the cops to come and I'm like why
wouldn't you just give her the damn card
cuz the lady kept telling her like all I
want is my card back and I'll leave you
alone but she was like stubborness book
and then the white lady was like oh you
think you're more sober than me Ani yeah
who calls the cops on a barbecue dude
like if I saw a barbecue and even if
they're not supposed to be that'd be
like what you cooking bro they weren't
supposed to use charcoal two hours did
you she's like you must have a lot of
time on your hands cuz I got [ __ ] to do
but yeah I'm more supper than you are
dude that means they had a full meal
they were drinking by then they were
playing what's their motive you know
like so so I mean what's her motive like
she's walking down and she goes I smell
to our power no I saw black people no
power or control they like assert
themselves a weird [ __ ] situation
that's even the white lady calls around
that video to like Oh what like you're
the only one that gets to have power in
this whole situation like you take my
card but then you're calling the cops on
these black dudes just having a normal
regular barbecue and for some reason
that bothers you so much and now you're
clinging on to this seem to me that's
like clearly like racist yeah like the
other ones it's like I don't know
yeah I mean sigh I feel like she's out
what is it we're done though the first
one I think it's crazy neighbor crazy
[ __ ] if she if her boyfriend is black
and then she has minority in like it
could be racism but I don't know it
doesn't get the description it's just
crazy annoying [ __ ] neighbor yeah
right but in this situation it's clearly
she has something against her shirt and
then the other one that we were talking
about the lawyer so there's this lawyer
that ends up going to this restaurant in
New York in Manhattan and he got so
upset and like so offended that the
workers at that place were speaking
Spanish to Spanish speakers oh this guy
yeah I didn't see this one but it was
going alright here we go
[Music]
just knock his ass out
[Music]
take a break you always know the
person's an [ __ ] when they walk like
this I had a sandwich like don't hit but
go hit by a car in New York New York or
LA right it's an international city like
we have a lot of tourists like we have a
lot of people who are visiting the
country young good money yeah you know
like USA like we we thrive on foreign
nationals coming in and spending money
in our cities and [ __ ] so what if in
this situation like it's a they get a
lot of people from the Caribbean and
South America coming to visit Puerto
Ricans or whatever and it just helps
when the employees can provide a better
service by speaking Spanish like that
well even if they're American that guy
just assumed that they're poor because
they're speaking Spanish yeah they're
welfare and they're immigrants right cuz
I'm document whenever we go to other
countries right we expect them to know a
little [ __ ] English yeah and then we
don't see the locals there going like
why don't [ __ ] you speaking English this
is [ __ ] Malaysia [ __ ] except
for managing their loneliness you only
do that if you're at Missa tee though so
you're like if I'm in Korea and I'm they
don't I'm Korean I can't speak Korean
don't talk [ __ ] yeah you know what I
mean
that's why if I go to Korea or if I'm
like it a bunch of cream people I just
tell my Chinese and I just speak Korean
yeah because they [ __ ] they're pressed
Kiseki yeah
[Music]
[Music]